WELCOME.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU TO
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS AT THIS
TIME.
IN A FEW MINUTES THE GRADUATE
PROCESSION WILL ENTER FROM THE
REAR OF THE AUDITORIUM AND WILL
BE USING BOTH AISLES.
IF ANY GRADUATES ARE HAVING
DIFFICULTY FINDING THEIR SEATS,
PLEASE FIND AN USHER TO ASSIST
YOU.
THANK YOU.
>> WE WOULD LIKE TO ASK EVERYONE
TO PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
THE FACULTY PROCESSION WILL
BEGIN SHORTLY.
THANK YOU.
♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, WELCOME
TO YALE UNIVERSITY.
EMERGENCY EXITS ARE LOCATED
THROUGHOUT THE BUILDING.
PLEASE TAKE A FEW MOMENTS TO
LOCATE THE EXIT CLOSEST TO YOU.
IN THE EVENT OF AN EMERGENCY,
REMAIN CALM.
EXIT IN AN ORDERLY FASHION AND
FOLLOW THE DIRECTIONS OF THE
UNIVERSITY AND PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICIALS.
THANK YOU.
>> ESTEEMED FACULTY, COLLEAGUES,
FAMILIES, FRIENDS AND STUDENTS.
I WELCOME YOU TO THE 318th
COMMENCEMENT OF YALE UNIVERSITY
AND TO THE 158th ANNIVERSARY
ON THE DATE ON WHICH YALE
CONFERRED ITS FIRST AND THE
NATION'S FIRST PH.D. DEGREE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
TODAY WE CELEBRATE OUR STUDENTS'
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AS SCHOLARS AND
RESEARCHERS.
AND WE AWARD THE DEGREES EARNED
BY YOUR DEDICATION TO THE
ADVANCEMENT OF HUMAN KNOWLEDGE.
WE'RE EXTREMELY PROUD OF WHAT
YOU HAVE ACHIEVED YOUR TIME AT
YALE AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO YOUR FIELD.
CONGRATULATIONS TO ALL OF YOU.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
AS WE BEGIN OUR CEREMONY, I WANT
TO FIRST RECOGNIZE THOSE
GRADUATE STUDENTS AND FACULTY
WHO RECEIVED PRIZES AT
YESTERDAY'S CLASS DAY.
AND LISTED ARE THE STUDENT
ACADEMIC PRIZES.
I ASK ALL STUDENT PRIZE WINNERS
AND THEIR ADVISERS PRESENT TO
STAND SO WE CAN THANK THE
ADVISERS FOR THEIR GUIDANCE AND
CONGRATULATE THE STUDENTS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
NOW NO ITS 21ST YEAR, THE
GRADUATE MENTOR AWARD CELEBRATE
FACULTY MEMBERS WHO HAVE BEEN
OUTSTANDING TEACHERS AND
ADVISERS OF GRADUATE STUDENTS.
THE THREE FACULTY MEMBERS WHO
RECEIVED THIS AWARD THIS YEAR
EXEMPLIFY THE MANY IMPORTANT
QUALITIES TO WHICH ALL GRADUATE
TEACHERS SHOULD ASPIRE.
I ASK OUR MENTOR PRIZE WINNERS
IN ATTENDANCE TODAY TO STAND SO
WE CAN AGAIN RECOGNIZE THEIR
ACHIEVEMENTS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PROFESSOR -- REPRESENTS THE
THREE FACULTY OUT OF ALL THE
FACULTY WHO HAVE HELPED YOU
NAVIGATE GRADUATE SCHOOL.
YOU HAVE ALSO BEEN SUPPORTED BY
MANY OTHERS ON CAMPUS WHOSE
LABOR AND LOYALTY CONTRIBUTE TO
MAKE YALE THE DISTINGUISHED
UNIVERSITY IT IS.
HERE ARE JUST A FEW.
THESE ARE PEOPLE BEYOND THE
FACULTY WHO STAND AT THE HEART
OF YALE.
AND WHEN I'VE FINISHED, WE CAN
THANK THEM TOGETHER.
THE UNIVERSITY'S CUSTODIAL AND
MAINTENANCE STAFF MAKE OUR
CAMPUS LOOK BEAUTIFUL AND KEEP
US ALL IN -- [ CHEERS AND
APPLAUSE ]
THE STAFF AT COMMENCEMENT AND
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
THE CLERICAL AND TECHNICAL STAFF
CONDUCT OUR BUSINESS WITH ACUMEN
AND DISPATCH.
WHERE WOULD WE BE WITHOUT OUR
REGISTER STARS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THE PROFESSIONAL STAFF DIRECT
AND ADMINISTER OUR DEPARTMENTS
AND SCHOOLS.
AND WE SHOULD SPECIFICALLY THANK
THE STAFF OF THE GRADUATE SCHOOL
OF ARTS AND SCIENCE WHO SUSTAIN
THE INSTITUTION WITHIN WHICH
YALE GRADUATES' EDUCATION
THRIVES.
FOR ALL THESE WOMEN AND MEN OF
YALE, I -- LET'S RECOGNIZE THEM
WITH APPLAUSE FROM EVERYONE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
WE ALSO NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
SUPERB MUSICAL ABILITIES OF OUR
ORGANIST, MR. CHASE LOOMER.
DOWN THERE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
ONE OF THE MANY ACCOMPLISHED
STUDENTS AT THE SCHOOL OF
MUSIC.
NOW, I WANT TO SAY JUST A FEW
WORDS TO YOU, OUR STUDENTS
RECEIVING DEGREES TODAY.
CANDIDATES FOR THE PH.D., M.
PHIL AND MASTERS DEGREE BEFORE
WE BEGIN CONFERRING YOUR
DIPLOMAS.
I KNOW FOR MANY OF YOU GETTING
TO THIS GRADUATION DAY HAS NOT
BEEN EASY, BUT UP PREVAILED.
YOU HAVE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF ALL
THE GRADUATE SCHOOL OFFERS AS
YOU PURSUED YOUR STUDIES AND
SCHOLARLY RESEARCH.
DURING YOUR TIME WITH US, YOU
HAVE LEARNED THE WAY OF RESEARCH
AND SCHOLARSHIP IS NEITHER
STRAIGHT NOR ALWAYS SMOOTH.
A LINE OF INQUIRY MAY TAKE YOU
NOWHERE.
AND MONTHS OF WORK MAY BEAR NO
FRUIT.
AN EXPERIMENT COULD GO AWRY.
AND YOU FIND YOURSELF BACK AT
SQUARE ONE.
WE HAVE BEEN TOLD THAT GRADUATE
STUDY TAKES INSPIRATION FOR
SURE.
BUT ALSO HARD WORK AND
ESPECIALLY PERSEVERANCE AND
DETERMINATION.
LEARNING TO CONTINUE IN THE FACE
OF CHALLENGES CHARACTERIZES THE
ABILITY TO DO ADVANCED
RESEARCH.
AND THE FACT THAT YOU SIT HERE
TODAY MEANS YOU HAVE LEARNED
THAT LESSON.
TODAY YOU LEAVE YALE AS
THINKERS, EXPLORERS, CREATORS,
TEACHERS.
AND AS MANY OF YOU HEARD AT OUR
RECENT "WHERE DO I GO FROM YALE?
"
DAY, YOU HAVE A SET OF SKILLS
THAT HAVE PREPARED YOU FOR
CAREERS, INNOVATIVE AND CRITICAL
THINKERS, PROBLEM SOLVERS,
LEADERS, TEAM PLAYERS AND
EFFECTIVE COMMUNITIERS POISED
FOR CAREERS.
WHATEVER DIRECTION YOU CHOOSE TO
APPLY YOUR SKILLS OF ADVANCED
LEARNING, LET YOUR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS HERE INSPIRE YOU
TO TACKLE NEW CHALLENGES WITH
THE CONFIDENCE THAT YOU HAVE THE
SKILL TO NAVIGATE ALL
DIFFICULTIES.
AS A YALE GRADUATE YOU ARE GIVEN
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CONTRIBUTE TO
SOCIETY AND TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE
IN YOUR FIELD OF STUDY.
As YOU GO FORTH, I HOPE THAT
YOU WILL ALSO STAY ENGAGED AND
IN TOUCH WITH US AS ALUMNI AND
CONSIDERING MENTORING THOSE WHO
FOLLOW IN YOUR FOOTSTEPS.
IT HAS BEEN MY PRIVILEGE TO LEAD
THE GRADUATE SCHOOL'S EFFORTS TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE ENVIRONMENT
IN WHICH YOU GREW TO THE
SCHOLARS YOU ARE TODAY.
I'M PROUD OF WHAT YOU'VE
ACCOMPLISHED AND EXCITED TO SEE
WHAT YOU WILL DO NEXT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
SO, WE WILL NOW AWARD THE
GRADUATE DEGREES.
WE WILL CALL THE GRADUATES TO
THE STAGE BY DEPARTMENT OR
PROGRAM IN WHICH THEY HAVE
EARNED THEIR DEGREES.
FOR THOSE STUDENTS RECEIVING
MORE THAN ONE DEGREE, ALL
DIPLOMAS WILL BE AWARDED
TOGETHER.
DEAN PAMELA SCHIRMEISTER WILL
READ THEM.
PLEASE COME FORWARD AS YOU ARE
CALLED.
WE WILL BE JOINED BY THOSE IN
THE PROGRAM ON THE STAGE.
YOU ARE MORE THAN WELCOME TO
GIVE APPLAUSE TO INDIVIDUALS AS
THEY GO ACROSS THE STAGE.
BUT WE DO NOT CONSIDER THAT
IMPOLITE AT ALL.
WE WELCOME IT.
DEAN SCHIRMEISTER.
DR. SCHIRMEISTER, FOR THE PH.D.
IN AFRICAN-AMERICAN STUDIES.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
AND FOR THE MASTERS DEGREE.
FOR THE MASTERS DEGREE IN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN STUDIES.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN AMERICAN
STUDIES.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
AND FOR THE MASTERS DEGREE -- [
APPLAUSE ]
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN ANTHROPOLOGY.
FOR THE PH.D. IN APPLIED
MATHEMATICS.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN APPLIED
PHYSICS.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
AND FOR THE MASTERS OF SCIENCE.
FOR THE MASTER OF ARTS IN
ARCHAEOLOGICAL STUDIES.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN ARCHITECTURE.
FOR THE PH.D. IN ASTRONOMY.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN CELL BIOLOGY.
FOR THE PH.D. IN CELLULAR AND
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
MOLECULAR PHYSIOLOGY.
FOR THE PH.D. IN CHEMISTRY.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN CLASSICS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN COMPARATIVE
LITERATURE.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN COMPUTATIONAL
BIOLOGY AND BIOINFORMATICS.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
AND FOR THE MASTERS OF SCIENCE.
FOR THE PH.D. IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
AND FOR THE MASTERS OF SCIENCE.
FOR THE PH.D. IN EAST ASIAN
LANGUAGES AND LITERATURES.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE MASTER OF ARTS IN EAST
ASIAN STUDIES.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN ECONOMICS.
FOR THE M. PHIL.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
AND IN ENGINEERING AND APPLIED
SCIENCES FOR THE PH.D. IN
BIOMEDICAL ENGINEERING.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
AND FOR THE MASTER OF SCIENCE.
AND FOR THE PH.D. IN CHEMICAL
AND ENVIRONMENTAL ENGINEERING.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
AND FOR THE MASTER OF SCIENCE.
AND FOR THE PH.D. IN ELECTRICAL
ENGINEERING.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
AND FOR THE MASTERS OF
PHILOSOPHY IN MECHANICAL
ENGINEERING AND SCIENCE.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN ENGLISH
LANGUAGE AND LITERATURE.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE MASTER OF ARTS.
FOR THE MASTER OF ARTS IN
EUROPEAN AND RUSSIAN STUDIES.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN EXPERIMENTAL
PATHOLOGY.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN FILM STUDIES.
FOR THE PH.D. IN FORESTRY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL STUDIES.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN FRENCH.
BETTER PH.D. IN GENETICS.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
BETTER PH.D. IN GEOPHYSICS.
FOR THE PH.D. IN GERMANIC
LANGUAGES AND LITERATURES.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN HISTORY.
AND FOR THE MASTER OF ARTS.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN THE HISTORY OF
ART.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN IMMUNOBIOLOGY.
FOR THE PH.D. IN THE
INTERDEPARTMENTAL NEUROSCIENCE
PROGRAM.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE MASTER OF ARTS IN
INTERNATIONAL AND DEVELOPMENT
ECONOMICS.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN INVESTIGATIVE
MEDICINE.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN ITALIAN
LANGUAGE AND LITERATURE.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN LAW.
-- AGAIN, FOR THE PH.D. IN LAW.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN LINGUISTICS.
FOR THE PH.D. IN MANAGEMENT.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
AND FOR THE MASTERS OF
PHILOSOPHY.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN MATHEMATICS.
FOR THE PH.D. IN MICROBIOLOGY.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE MASTERS OF SCIENCE.
AND FOR THE PH.D. IN MOLECULAR
BIOPHYSICS AND BIOCHEMISTRY.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IF MOLECULAR,
CELLULAR AND DEVELOPMENTAL
BIOLOGY.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN MUSIC.
FOR THE PH.D. IN NEAR EASTERN
LANGUAGES AND CIVILIZATIONS.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE MAST MASTER OF ARTS.
FOR THE H P.D. IN NURSING.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN PHARMACOLOGY.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES [
FOR THE PH.D. IN PHILOSOPHY.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN PHYSICS.
FOR THE PH.D. IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN PSYCHOLOGY.
FOR THE PH.D. IN PUBLIC HEALTH.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
BLOOD PRESSURE AND FOR THE
MASTER OF
AND FOR THE MASTER OF SCIENCE.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN RELIGIOUS
DECEASE.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
AND FOR THE MASTER OF
PHILOSOPHY.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
AND FOR THE M. PHIL IN
RENAISSANCE DECEASE.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN SLAVIC
LANGUAGES.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE PH.D. IN SOCIOLOGY.
FOR THE MASTERS OF PHILOSOPHY.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
AND FOR THE MAST OF ARTS.
FOR THE PH.D. IN SPANISH AND
PORTUGUESE.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
AND FOR THE MASTER OF ARTS.
FOR THE PH.D. IN STATISTICS AND
DATA SCIENCE.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
FOR THE MASTER OF ARTS AND
STATISTICS.
[  READING OF GRADUATE NAMES  ]
OKAY.
NOW I ASK, AS I CALL OUT EACH
DEGREE, FOR THE RECIPIENTS OF
THAT DEGREE TO STAND AND REMAIN
STANDING.
AFTER WHICH WE CAN CONGRATULATE
ALL OF THEM TOGETHER.
MASTER OF ARTS.
STAND.
MASTER OF SCIENCE.
MASTER OF ADVANCED STUDIES.
MASTER OF PHILOSOPHY.
DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
OKAY.
DON'T SIT DOWN.
STAY RIGHT THERE.
IT'S ONE OF OUR TRADITIONS AT
THIS POINT TO RECOGNIZE THE
COMMITMENT OF TIME, EFFORT AND
ATTENTION REQUIRED TO ACHIEVE AN
ADVANCED DEGREE IS ONLY POSSIBLE
WITH THE PARTICIPATION AND
SUPPORT NOT ONLY OF YOUR
PROFESSORS AND CLASSMATES, BUT
ALSO YOUR FAMILIES AND FRIENDS.
THEREFORE, I INVITE YOU, ALL OF
OUR DEGREE RECIPIENTS, TO TURN
AND ACKNOWLEDGE ROLES PLAYED BY
OTHERS IN THE ACHIEVEMENT WE ARE
CELEBRATING TODAY.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
OKAY.
NOW YOU CAN SIT DOWN.
YOU HAVE SPENT TIME IN ONE OF
CIVILIZATIONS HIGHEST
INVENTIONS.
THE RESEARCH UNIVERSITY.
WHERE THE MISSION IS THE
CREATION OF NEW KNOWLEDGE.
AS YOU'VE LEARNED, FINDING NEW
KNOWLEDGE, NEW TRUTHS, ABOUT OUR
WORLD IS NOT A SOLITARY
ENDEAVOR.
YOU HAVE LIVED WITHIN AN
ACADEMIC NETWORK IN WHICH YOU
CAN FOLLOW YOUR CURIOSITY,
RIGOROUSLY TEST YOUR IDEAS, HAVE
THE CRITIQUES THAT SPARK NEW
IDEAS AND GO IN UNEXPECTED
DIRECTIONS.
YOU HAVE LEARNED THAT A
CONVINCING ARGUMENT BACKED BY
EVIDENCE FROM PRIMARY SOURCES OR
WELL-CONTROLLED EXPERIMENTS WILL
STAND UP TO CRITIQUES.
AND IMPORTANTLY, PAVE THE WAY
FOR THE NEXT PERSON TO TAKE
ANOTHER STEP.
SAVOR THIS, REJOICE IN THIS.
IT IS A RARE PRIVILEGE TO LIVE
THIS EXPERIENCE.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT IT IS NOW
YOUR RESPONSIBILITY TO SPREAD
THAT KNOWLEDGE BEYOND THE
UNIVERSITY.
WHATEVER -- WHEREVER YOUR FUTURE
TAKES YOU, SHARE WHAT YOU HAVE
LEARNED AND WHAT YOU WILL
LEARN.
OUR WORLD NEEDS TO KNOW TRUE
THINGS BACKED BY HARD-WON
EVIDENCE NOW MORE THAN EVER.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
BE A SOURCE OF TRUTH IN THE
MIDST OF CONFUSION AND
MISINFORMATION.
AND BRING ALL YOUR WISDOM TO
BEAR ON THAT TRUTH.
BE THE MENTOR OF YOUNG, CURIOUS
PEOPLE WHO ARE BUDDING TRUTH
SEEKERS.
TAKE WHAT YOU HAVE LEARNED AT
YALE AND MAKE THE WORLD A BETTER
PLACE.
ON BEHALF OF ALL OF US AT YALE,
CONGRATULATIONS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
GRADUATES, FAMILIES, FRIENDS,
TOGETHER WITH THE FACULTY AND
STAFF WHO ARE WITH US ARE
INVITED TO A RECEPTION
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING THE
CONCLUSION OF THIS CEREMONY AT
THE COURTYARD AT THE McDOUGAL
CENTER.
ALL THE STUDENTS STARTED OUT IT
THIS MORNING.
PLEASE JOIN US FOR THIS
CELEBRATORY OCCASION.
AS THE SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WILL BE HOLDING ITS GRADUATION
CEREMONY IMMEDIATELY AFTER OURS,
PLEASE ALL REMAIN IN YOUR SEATS
UNTIL THE PLATFORM PARTY
RECESSES FROM THE AUDITORIUM.
THEN PLEASE PROCESS OUT TO THE
RECEPTION UNDER THE GUIDANCE OF
OUR USHERS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪